la grande-bretagne durement touchée par
la quatrième vague devient le premier
pays à approuver un nouveau type de
médicament tiko vide offert sous forme
de pilules le menu pire à dire
le mot ni pu ravir fabriqués par les
multinationales marque est un antiviral
développé à l'origine pour soigner la
grippe puis testé avec succès contre
halak au vide ici pas de traitement
intraveineux sous supervision médicale
comme c'est le cas pour les autres
médicaments disponibles qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est bon c'est un
autre arsenal est une autre tiens dans
l'arsenal pour la défense contre la
commis 19 le premier avantage penser que
c'est un traitement par voie orale puis
on sait que la voie orale c'est la voie
royale le mode d'emploi est simple il
doit être pris à la maison un début
d'infection à raison de deux comprimés
par jour pendant cinq jours il est
offert uniquement aux patients à risque
d'hospitalisation élevé en raison de
problèmes de coeur d'obésité ou de
diabète par exemple même si les données
concernant l'efficacité de cet antiviral
n'ont pas encore été publiés les experts
anglais qu'ils ont consultés ont été
convaincus de 14% en moyenne le risque
d'hospitalisation des groupes de
patients étudiés aurait diminué de
moitié à 7% avec ce traitement selon
marc incliné qui ont démontré exemple
que des gens qui étaient allés là
coville reprenant le mot nu-pieds la
vire après une certaine période de temps
donc relativement courte durée 4 heures
au canada ce médicament est toujours en
attente d'une approbation par les
autorités réglementaires
s'il reçoit le feu vert des
administrations publiques devront
également se prononcer sur son prix
estimé pour l'instant à 800 dollars par
traitement ici normand grondin radio
canada montréal